I am 5 9, and I'm probably like, 165 ish pounds,
and I get a size large. This is how it fits.
I don't like to be fucking squeezed.
Like, if I got it,
I could get it in a medium, and I could fit in a medium,
but it would,
like, suck it in,
and that just makes my stomach hurt.
I'm okay with people understanding I have intestines,
so. And then sometimes, like today,
I don't wanna be in the full fucking pink.
Like, what's up?
I'm in fucking pink.
I just wear, like,
a little sweater.
Tone it down a bit.
So kind of wear it like this.
I really like it.
It's really cute set.
It's really comfy.
I do like how bright it is.
Like, even if I'm wearing a jacket,
like, my little bright pink legs are sticking out.
So if you want one of the link right here.